التصنيف الامريكي لمجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
كمؤسسه اجراميه عابره للحدود تلقاه رئيسها
بتهكما وصفا الامريكيين بالزملاء
فيفجنى برجان الذي كان حتى الامس القريب
يعرف بطباخ بوتن اصبح يجادل على سلب
بطولات مجموعته في اوكرانيا لبن يفاخر
علنا بامتلاكه دبابات وطائرات
تاسست عام 2014 بعد ضم روسيا شبه جزيره
القرم الاوكرانيه تسع سنوات خاضتها
المجموعه في الضله صاحبت طموحات بوتين
والتهمت بخدمه مصالحه نفذت خلالها مهمات
سريه للكريم لان على مسارح حوالي 30 دوله
بدا من سوريا مع التدخل الروسي فيها عام
2015 ثم فنزويلا وولدان الافريقيه عده في
مقدمتها ليبيا ومالي وجمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى والسودان ومدغشقر وموزمبيقه غير
انا العم العسكريه في اوكرانيا اخرجتها
للعلن وخلال اقل من عام تحولت فاجنر من
قوه نخبه صغيره نسبيه ارسلت المرتزقه الى
سوريا وافريقيا الى تشكيل متعدد المستويات
بحجم فيلاقه وتقدر واشنطن عدد افرادها ب
50,000 بينهم نحو 40 الف مدانا جندتهم من
السجونه فيما الاتهامات تلاحقها باستلام
شحنه اسلحه من كوريا الشماليه
مهمات فاجنر السريه الاوليه تمثلت بتدريب
الميليشيات المدعومه من روسيا تلاها
الاستطلاع قبل الاطلاع بدور البطوله في
بخمه وتحول لخط الامامي للقوات الروسيه
بعد خسائر متتاليه وفيما تصور فاجنر نفسها
على انها الوحده الروسيه الوحيده القدره
على شان عمليه هجوميه تراها موسكو كبشه
فداء ان تنسب اليه